How do you improve on perfection?
You cover it with pumpkin spice and chocolate sauce.
That's right, McDonald's Japan is jumping on the pumpkin spice bandwagon this Halloween...
...with this limited menu item.
Delicious.
For customers at this McDonald's in Tokyo,...
...the Halloween choco potato was unveiled to a warm reception.
"The flavors of pumpkin and chocolate went unexpectedly well," this person said.
"The saltiness harmonized with the sweetness," said another.
"I really enjoyed it."
McDonald's Japan said the idea for pumpkin and chocolate flavored fries...
...follows the enthusiasm for their regular chocolate-covered fries,...
...McChoco Potatoes, which were released in January.
Looks like Halloween just got a whole lot scarier.